Kim fields is done with the Real  Housewives of Atlanta  the 46 year old Dancing with the Stars  contestant called into the Rickey smiley  morning show Monday and when asked if  she'll be returning to the Housewives  franchise she coyly responded you know  it's done get in and get out et recently  spoke with Kim's Housewives co-star  Cynthia Bailey and Kenya Moore who  didn't feel she was a fit from the start  never really got to really see Kim  coming to her beauty also caught up with  the facts of life actress after the  taping of Monday night's premiere of  Dancing with the Stars where she was  still vague on her Housewives state  overall at the start of it it was more  of a you know put your toe in the water  is this gonna be like Brett Favre and  the Jets one and done you know always  stay open and you see what happens